were accused in his second fatal DUI
crash had a valid driver's license which
enabled him to rent a car our 8 news now
investigators learning the DMV revoked
that license six days after
he got behind the wheel killing a man
again eight news now investigator David
charns reports
case is the perfect storm of just about
every single failure of our Criminal
Justice System combined into one messy
package of a dumpster fire that's how
prosecutor Noreen Damonte describes what
led up to 50-year-old Prentice Bates
facing his second fatal DUI charge good
morning are you Prentice Bates yes ma'am
Nate seen here in a parole Hearing in
2020 served eight years in prison for
killing 58-year-old Jim burchett in
2012. Bates was high on drugs driving a
car rented to another person I made a
bad terrible decision by choosing to
operate in more vehicle-wide under the
influence during the hearing a parole
board member notes Bates was never in
substance misuse treatment while in
custody and in your criminal history a
lot of repetitive drug and alcohol
crime offenses the full board ultimately
giving Bates parole eight years to the
day of his first fatal crash the man
standing in front of you today has
transformed immensely but prosecutors
say Bates did not change by June of this
year Metro Police charged him with DUI
again that set off the manual process of
revoking his driver's license because of
his prior DUI conviction the eight news
now investigators learning the Nevada
Department of Motor Vehicles did not
receive that request until August 22nd
the DMV did not process the revocation
notice until September 28th six days
after police say Bates once again high
on drugs slammed into 40-year-old Demar
Sims killing him failure utter and
complete failure well a judge had
ordered Bates not to drive Damonte says
having his license pulled in State
records could have prevented him from
running the car police say he was
driving in the latest deadly crash sure
yeah he'd have that little card in his
hand but when somebody goes to run that
rental car companies may be pulled over
by an officer it's going to show up as
revoked Bates is in jail awaiting his
next court hearing he is being held
without bail I'm David charns 8 News Now
final note here a spokesperson for the
DMV stresses Bates would still have his
physical license and that a judge had
ordered him not to drive back in June
we've asked why it took three months to
process and we're still waiting for a
response